[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time to bust more myths in quad
night as always if you have a question
for the myth chases to test please put
it in the comments below and your myth
could be chosen on next week's episode
please think about using code a Demario
if you like this series it helps keep
the lights on so the helicopter was
added in for a night this week instead
of starting with a brand new myth we're
going back in time to about four weeks
ago because this is too good to ignore
get your eye holes around this shadow
agents can unlock ghost doors it's a
good myth can the face recognition
software be fooled by an enemy henchman
in the past we've tried this but every
time we got close the henchman would
vanish into thin air
but now the chopper is here can we claim
a shadow henchman take them all the way
to the agency and open a sealed door
here's how it's going down two of us
went to pleasant Park to get a henchman
and the chopper under the field while
two others went to the agency and
cleared a path for us it was going to be
tight in terms of timing but we were
confident and guess what see for
yourself
[Music]
myth confirmed shadow henchmen can
indeed open ghost doors to really flex
on this myth we went the opposite
direction
taking a ghost henchman to a shadow
weapons cache and check this it works
perfectly we did this multiple times to
really confirm this myth and it all
comes down to those lovely choppers in
the sky damn I'm impressed
now let's keep this going next myth
friendly BOTS
will use a chopper hmm I like this into
battle loved we go you'd think this
would be super easy wouldn't you well
check out what happens every single
grenades and BOTS inside completely
ignores the chopper and simply runs away
from it to counteract this I thought I
was being smart I built a wall to force
them into the chopper and what do you
think they did they pickaxe the chopper
to get around it bad times so myth
busted BOTS will not use choppers so
then we have to try this with decoys
this is also a fail when thrown down
they run away from the chopper and get
this throwing decoys inside the chopper
causes this to happen absolutely nothing
at all the decoy never even appears
making the decoy grenades
terrible flash banks rip the dream next
myth well well this is more of a
question actually what happens to the
chopper at steamie stacks I had high
hopes that the chopper would be held up
by the steam but this is what actually
happens well nothing the updraft slows
the chopper slightly but to no avail it
can descend here and it can even be at
rest on top of the purple stuff what a
letdown
it's actually a bit of a fogger to get
back in once you park this thing so
protip watch out for the propellers
here's a weird myth a falling boat will
destroy a chopper what do you think to
this I got my backside over to the docks
and set up the chopper under the bolt
held up by a crane will the boat cause
the chopper to explode let's see
[Music]
nope Wow well that was there was totally
anticlimactic myth busted let's crack on
Jody MC says it's possible to hide c4
inside a chopper and explode it later in
the game okay so there's two parts to
this myth first let's see if it's
possible to hide c4 inside the
helicopter and look at this it certainly
is possible to hide it here normally the
c4 sticks out in plain sight but if we
throw it to the backseat there's a
chance that it will be completely out of
sight and out of mind the second part of
the myth was to explode the c4 as you'd
expect it works really well from close
distance but the c4 has a range limit to
test it to the extreme we flew to
opposite sides of the island to attempt
the longest distance kill in Port Knight
history but sadly it did not trigger the
c4 was still functional when shots but
the signal needs to be close enough to
manually trigger the explosives another
note is where the c4 is placed matters a
great deal
we found that smashing the pilot screen
and throwing c4 in there is the most
opie spot on the choppers every day is a
school day next myth can explosive
barrels be thrown onto the chopper oh no
it says thrown into a chopper okay okay
good myth let's try it one part of this
myth can be debunked immediately if you
attempt to throw an explosive container
into the chopper well it's like hitting
a brick wall it bounces straight back
out again so this is where we changed
our attempt we are going to change our
plan we attempted to land the canister
on the side panel and check this out we
got it to land so myth confirmed
wealth cut cut the music cut the music
we have an issue the moment the
cannister lands it holds the chopper in
place making flying away impossible when
the helicopter did get clear the
canister floated in mid-air just stayed
there
spooky and more often than not the
choppers rotor blades would cause an
explosion so this is a busted myth got
it we double-checked this just in case
it was because the helicopter was
touching the ground and no the same
thing happens when you throw it on an
airborne helicopter
next me and you land the bottle flip on
a chopper I like the way you think yeah
bottle flip myths check this out we
found out that to have a chance at this
the helicopter must be even under steady
and then with enough attempts it finally
happened the bottle flip on a chopper is
mastered I had hoped to fly this around
the map but look what happens the bottle
falls through the helicopter and land
absolutely perfectly on whatever's
underneath this is our pointless
information but I had fun all the same
next myth Rhys Brady asks can a chopper
catch a Supply Drop well this one's for
you dude
I ventured into the world waiting to
pounce on any unsuspecting Supply Drop I
had such an unlucky time everyone that
spawned was so far away it made it
almost impossible to get there in time
luckily I found two the first I
encountered I attempted to catch in
midair I found that the Supply Drop
bounced me away instantly I tried again
from above and to my surprise the
balloon burst so a chopper can cut down
supply drops I then tested the strength
of a Supply Drop against the chopper
blade and by far the Supply Drop wins so
I ran away to find another on this one I
attempted to land on top epic fail
moving on now here we go this one was
perfect
a perfectly flat floor to catch the drop
I took out a tree trying to cause issues
and waited in the perfect spot for the
drop could we catch it well here we go
absolute perfection
bang in the center point I defended the
drop with my life until the moment came
to fly away could we lift the drop and
no but hey myth proven we can catch a
supply drop on a chopper GG our next
myth is a functional warning campfires
heal choppers I like it so off I ran to
the agency and partially destroyed the
chopper there I then took it to a fire
pit would it work and look at this it
works perfectly the chopper loved its
day out it acted like a puppy eating
dinner healing by the campfire useful to
know isn't it anyway 10 minutes later I
had fully restored the chopper it was
good as new
so let's go back to that hole in the
chopper check out this myth we can
rocket ride through a chopper window wow
we got to start small on this one let's
build up to this first we test it if
grenades could pass through and they
totally come next step we tried
proximity mines and nope they they get
stuck so sometimes this is a solid
sometimes it's a complete hole so here's
the moment of truth can we fly a rocket
through there and yes it works perfectly
so let's quickly bring in another myth a
rocket can travel through multiple
helicopters so we lined it up three
choppers do you think the rocket will
make it through all three check it out
damn that was epic good me so now's the
time let's rock it right through this
window here we go what the hell was what
what is this we tried again and again
and again and uh oh the rocket fly
through but there is something
preventing a player from going through
that hole
it is completely blocked we cannot enter
the backseats devastating please epic
games if you see this remove that solid
object we need to fly through nine
choppers it has to be turned in replay
mode this is what happens when you
absolutely nail the positioning it just
vanishes why why so sadly this is a
busted myth but there is a use for this
if you need to quickly get up to a
chopper you can use a rocket and easily
land on the side of the helicopter so
every cloud has a silver lining or
whatever the hell they say so there we
have it those are the myths for this
week if you've got another one throw it
in the comments and please upvote your
favorites to make it easier for me to
spot them on screen now are the people
who are kind enough to use my code in
the fort night shop it means the
absolute world to me I say this every
week but I mean it you're all legands
thank you so much okay thank you so much
for your time I am Adam from Playstation
grenades
you're awesome stay that way
[Music]